on the mound for the halos no record yet
this year making his second start of the
season as a 1.93 era had a really good
first start and we haven't seen him in
almost 15 days
but he's back on the mound here tonight
the right-hander shohei ohtani and the
pitch and that one misses outside and
on with a walk second battery of the
game david dahl full count pitch it is
inside and that's going to be the second
straight walk after the lead-off man was
retired so gallo was on here's the next
pitch
and that one is a fastball and that one
misses so
three walks in a
row and now ohtani is in a bases loaded
jam with one out
and
all these have been free base runners
here big pitch here now for shohei and
the angels
got him
right over the top of that one it
disappeared down and away split-fingered
fastball
nasty split straight down
clearly swung on that one
the grip
no issues throwing a splitter with his
blister on his finger
so here is calhoun two outs they're
loaded the one-two pitch
got him split-fingered fastball and down
goes calhoun kazani had to work really
hard in the inning
he loaded up the bases with one out on
walks comes back strikes out the next
two and they leave him loaded how about
the season numbers for jordan lyle so
far this season this will be his fourth
start of the year see the era a little
bit high but the strikeouts have been
fantastic 13 of them in 15 and a third
innings to just three walks one out and
one on and it brings up mike trout two
pitch and that's on the inside corner
strike three called struck him out three
times
in last night's ball game and kicking
this one off with another strikeout of
mike trout shohei otani faced
six batters in the top of the first
inning
so we'll see how he does here in the
second rips that split adjust if needed
they didn't need to
held on to it yes are they saying he
held on to it above the dirt
yeah yeah
he got that well above the dirt that's a
nice job catching by the way in the foul
tip keeping it above dirt there's a
split you start that one away with a
target set away and very difficult to
get a hitter to chase it and now a
single with two outs kinder feleffa
who hit 280 last season is hitting 200
right now he's over his last 17 and
there's a pitch that he misses the ball
got away from the catcher suzuki picks
it up though fires the first and the
strikeout will end the inning and he got
him on a splitter here's joey gallo
the o2
split-fingered fastball and down goes
gallow that was a strike yeah that was a
good pitch he's thinking you know i just
saw your jeep tools of the trade i want
to stick with that strikeout on a split
and he does that's a strike and a swing
the man leading things off wears number
44. he has done some damage in his time
in the big leagues there's there have
been angels through the years that have
worn 44 that have done a whole lot of
damage as scott scheibler drives that
one toward left field into the corner up
against the wall hustling around scott
schedler back in the big leagues with a
double wait that one came very close to
leaving out by the short wall there
shipler's first at bat as an angel
double and angels have a runner in
scoring position
suzuki fly ball right schedler look at
the tag
heads back to the bag off to the races
gallow fires toward third with the slide
shufflers in there so here's david
fletcher they've brought the infield in
and here's the first pitch on david he
swings at that one lifts the fly ball
into right center field now it's not all
that deep it'll be gallow makes the
catch shetler is going to tag here's the
throw to deflate and he is safe
wow
jebeler taking a two around the bases
things getting interesting very quickly
for him as an angel jose trevino will be
the next batter
yes fastball
i love when shohei trusts
his fastball i do too
six strikeouts so that puts a couple on
now final battle of the outing for
ohtani the 2-2
got him split-fingered fastball and down
goes connor
and that very likely is the last pitch
of the night for
shohei ohtani mike trout leads off the
angels fourth angel's leading the game
one nothing trout swings at the first
pitch lifts one in the air into left
center field and the ball drops in
between doll and garcia
no one apparently called for it they
both looked at each other and trout has
a big time gift wrap double he's at
second base and a big break right there
for mike trout trout moves to third so
albert is the batter
and to the dirt it goes here comes mike
trout to score
two to nothing halos solac is over too
he has struck out flight out this ball
hit pretty well out to left field back
on it upton that ball is gone
a home run
and solace gets it done the rangers are
on the board just like that it's a
one-run game a towering home run for
solac
we went down and got a breaking ball
what do you make of the night from mike
trout jose mota trying to figure out
exactly where he is time-wise you know
we talked about direction
on what he's working on today early bp
he is trying to get trying to get back
to that timing in the foot and also his
head where it is
i think he just did it i think he just
did it the timing is back yes he did and
it
boy is put a charge into that one well
over 400 feet
trout's fifth home run of the season
angels add-on it's now 3-1
mammoth home run for mike trout his 39th
of his career versus the rangers shall
we gallow the hit huge lead at third for
kinder philippa because there's nobody
within i don't know
70 feet of the base and there's a bunt
to third base and kind of falafel scores
without a play gallow has a base hit and
an rbi
so the angels getting ready to bat here
as we go to the bottom of the seventh
leading three to two new one on albert
he swings and drives the ball deep into
center field that ball is going to get
out a home run
albert goes deep here and the angel's
lead gets a little bit bigger it's now
4-2
that is how you get the run back albert
pujols
664th career home run 429th
different pitcher albert pools has
homered against
dead center for the machine
ball was crushed
by albert
hearn has made
15 pitches already since coming in and
eight of them have been out of the
strike zone
here's his 1-1
that balls hit high and deep down the
left side it's tight to the line fairer
foul it's out of here
kurt suzuki's first home run as an angel
two-run shot the lead keeps growing it's
now 6-2 angels one out single for the
short staff for the rangers and it
brings up david dalder left fielder
rolls that one out where they'll get one
out where they will get two outs
you betcha angel's turn the twin killing
and the ball game is over halos with a
nice bounce back win here tonight beat
the rangers 6-2